ken is with us in Sacramento hi Ken
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave's nice to talk with you the reason
that I'm calling is that I recently
inherited a great sum of money
approximately fifty million dollars and
I'm just wondering what do you think I
should do with this you're not kidding
me no I'm not kidding you
who in the world left you 50 million
dollars
my parents Wow what did they do uh my
dad was into everything real estate
he was an automobile dealer he sold
private jets Wow on and on and on so 50
million dollars cash or worth of assets
if no it's this is cash good nurse
gracious okay have you managed wealth
prior to this yeah okay so you're you
were already wealthy I I was comfortable
okay nothing like this but but at least
in the millions okay right and 1 million
would be wealthy right right so that's
called as we all know a millionaire
everybody except Washington which they
think millionaire means you may come in
here but anyway the thing that I do and
that I teach people to do with all of
their income including an unbelievable
sum like this is to balance and use
ratios between living some of it
enjoying some of it in other words
giving some of it and investing some of
it and so I would say ok how much of
this do I want to systematically give
because wealthy people who give are the
ones that have fun with money and I'm
gonna I'm going to spend some of it I'm
not going to be you know stack it all up
in a cave somewhere and I'm going to
enjoy some of it there's all I've always
wanted this car or I've always wanted to
go on this trip or I've always gonna buy
this for my wife or whatever that kind
of a thing but it's not a lot it doesn't
have to be like I don't have to be a
very big percentage with as much money
and it's a lot of money right
you know just kind of flow money almost
and then a percentage to invest yet for
the next generation
and to create income to do even yet more
giving and so forth so I would sit down
and think in ratios like that and say
okay I'm going to I'm going to give this
now I'm an evangelical Christian so I
tithe
that's a tenth of my income for I start
anything then I do giving additionally
to that on my ratio and then I invest a
ratio and I spend a small percentage but
you're going to have a lot of the
spending portion is going to be them
take much here for it to be a lot of fun
you